so what are rational numbers irrational
numbers and real numbers
let's see let's first understand
rational numbers a rational number is a
number which we can write in the p over
q form your p and q are integers and the
value of q cannot be equal to 0 the
examples of rational numbers are 1.5 5
over 6 negative 7 over 12 and so on so
what is an irrational number an
irrational number is a number which
cannot be written in the p over q form
the examples are square root of 2 square
root of 3 or pi
and what are real numbers
well rational numbers and irrational
numbers together
form real numbers
so if any number is rational or
irrational it will be a real number
there's another way to understand real
numbers any number that can be plotted
on a number line is a real number
now this concept was quite easy before
leaving don't forget to give us the
answers to these questions